Yeah, copy that. I had your location close to Villa Cortez and Palisades Drive. I've got two addresses that we have elderly trapped in.
Roger that. Got in just 71-37-59-292, the leader strike team, 1041.
Yeah, copy that. Let me give you the addresses and then let me know who you're going to send to those locations.
I've got 131339 Ava Villa-Cortez, 17107 Palisades Drive.
That's a different community.
We're at, again, 618-750 Palisades Drive.
Copy.
Operations, L.A. County Assistant, 42 on command.
Yeah, L.A. County, go for operations.
Yes, sir, I got three strike teams, two Charleys, one Alpha,
over in PCH and Coastline Drive in the community,
looking about 10 to 15 minutes before impact.
I'd like to make this Coastline Structured Defense Group,
and if you could let me know what tack I can operate on.
Yeah, copy that, Coastline Structured Defense.
Does that also incorporate the Getty, the Getty via?
Yeah, I believe so.
So we'll start pushing our three resources in here.
Yeah, copy that.
Can you give me those numbers again that are in your Structured Defense group?
1870 Charlie, 1151 Charlie, 1103 Alpha.
Copy.
70 Charlie 51 Charlie 03 Alpha.
Coastline Structure Defense Group.
And what tack can I operate on?
We'll give you V-Fire 25 for your tack.
Copy. V-Fire 25, thank you.
Let them know that we're here.
Coastline Structured Defense from 1151 Charlie.
You up on command?
Yeah, 1151 Charlie.
Stage your resources at Coastline and PCH.
You can continue up.
Hang a right on Surf View.
You'll meet me at the top.
Coastline Structured Defense Group.
We've already lined out our resources off of Surf View along with 1870.
I also want to let you know that Getty Villa is being impacted at the end on the north side of that.
Okay, copy that.
We can start engaging our crews there, and we're going to be on V-Fire 25, V-Fire 25.
Okay, Coastline Structure Defense, 1151 Charlie.
We're going to go to V-Fire 25.
And bring our resources in here.